[Music]  here's the premise  if you don't want one of these two uh  fellas to be president then you are  crazy do you feel crazy  yeah so do we when did it become  dangerous to have  common sense and how do we escape this  duopoly trap  well we can reject this lunacy together  unity 2020 is a patriotic plan to  restore the republic and empower our  democracy  by nominating two patriots from the left  and the right we can  end the partisan corruption that's  divided us and unite america  is it guaranteed to work no is it  radical  apparently is it crazy yeah but it's the  right kind of crazy  if this stupid year has taught us  anything it's that we have no idea what  is possible  now take one more look at the sensible  candidates  which of these is the future of our  country  unity 2020 common sense is the new crazy